after an 18-hour killing spree here in a
shopping center in a shootout with
Special Forces a Thai gunman siege
finally ends
[Music]
soldier Jack upon Toma is dead his mass
shooting unprecedented in Thailand in
the city of nakhon ratchasima devastated
families wait to collect the dead among
them not to watch 13 year old son Andrey
over money
the gunman murders his commanding
officer and steals weapons from his
barracks before heading to the city more
we're circled he opens fire again once
inside he calmly walks the corridors gun
in hand terrified shoppers tried to flee
but a trapped mark hid for six hours
with customers in his store finally
unwelcome look having one car I am jitta
one can do you can look after Alania no
man can come you can long hi we talked
about harmony after something than this
one same but another couple I'm a human
family at a city temple others had no
time to escape bullet holes in walls and
forensic marks on the ground evidence of
the violence carried out here
worshippers were gunned down as they
came to pray it's really disturbing to
see just how many of these circles monk
the places where the bullets fell and it
appears that the gunman came through the
gates here and then just started
shooting firing off round after round
shooting outside shooting here none some
rich shows me where she found the bodies
among the dead a mother and her child
were to me and nothing good near
fortunate enough in photos icon
so now a city remembers their dead for
the dozens of lives stolen in a massacre
for the hundreds of survivors forever
changed sky knees Thailand